mais qu alors parmi les supporters qui
doivent se rendre en italie mercredi une
marseillaise pas tout à fait comme les
autres antoinette ségara elle a 70 ans
elle a déjà été opéré deux fois à coeur
ouvert elle est une supportrice
inconditionnelle de l'om tout est prêt
dans les moindres détails
jean claude valentin henri lelièvre
l'ont rencontré je m'en vais équipés de
mon survêtement de mon survêtement et de
demain mon petit rico que ma fille m'a
offert c'est ma fille qui vont faire ça
pour la fête des mères c'est moi qui lui
ai demandé 1
voilà ma casquette mon foulard que
j'espère faire dédicacer par les joueurs
puisque je n'arrive pas à le faire ici à
marseille je vais essayer de le faire à
bari voilà je fais rire essayez de
j'aimerais avoir la signature de
monsieur tapie alors là ce serait une
grande joie pour moi
voilà ce fait longtemps vous êtes
supporter ruse la wii très longtemps il
ya 20 ans viennent plainte en 25 ans
bientôt je suis supportrice de loin et
que je que j'assiste à tous les matchs
puisque je suis sociaux